[Música]
todos nos hemos preguntado en algún
momento de nuestra vida sobre el futuro
económico de nuestros padres entonces
nos preguntamos en qué
cómo y con quién invertir
esta es la historia de una chica que
ahorró durante dos años y trató de
convencer a su padre de hacer una
inversión hasta que lo logró tomaron la
decisión en base a las experiencias
laborales de él y los gustos de él y
decidieron invertir en el sector de
transporte específicamente en el
servicio de grúas para vehículos
cuando dieron inicio al proceso de
negociación con una entidad bancaria
pero con un intermediario cuando éste se
dio cuenta que era la chica quien
llevaba la batuta dijo yo con mujeres no
negocio y además si no tienen
experiencia casi se cae el negocio socio
decidieron invertir o dar inicio al
proceso directamente pero esto les
ocasionó algunos obstáculos como falta
de conocimiento en el procedimiento de
validación de cuestiones técnicas del
vehículo homologación de furgón a grúa
porque el vehículo era de segunda y esto
generó sobre costos los sobrecostos
necesitan de liquidez es allí donde
debían acceder a créditos pero para
acceder a créditos ser soltera
independientes sin hijos ser dueña de un
gato no aplica
entonces era un personaje de alto riesgo
para las entidades bancarias claro les
tocó acceder a esos créditos de altas
tasas de interés para dar continuidad al
proceso
dando continuidad al proceso la chica se
comunicaba con el asesor responsable
pero ésta era muy escueto con ella a
pesar de que ella conocía mucho el tema
y tenía todo en orden los papeles del
proceso y se identificó que el asesor
con su padre era muy abierto entonces la
estrategia que implementaron fue que
cada vez que hacían una consulta con el
asesor el papá y la chica se reunían
para que el papá pudiera hablar con el
asesor ya el asesor lo atendiera bien
continuando con el proceso pasamos al
canchón el planchón es la parte de atrás
donde suben los vehículos a la máquina
resulta que este servicio y este
producto es muy escaso en la ciudad de
cali lograron contratar un servicio pero
éste no cumplió
las deudas ya llegaron las cuotas de los
préstamos ya empezaban a cursar pero no
habían ingresos
lograron identificar un planchón de
segunda
lo empezaron a montar pero aquí tuvieron
que hacer una negociación de pierde y
gana porque no había más
además de que lamentablemente él podía
tomarse el tiempo que deseaba
ella a causa de este estrés tan
inmanejable empieza a perder el cabello
y empieza a generar patologías que
afectaban su salud
cierto lograron hacerlo lograron
enfrentarlo y lograron solucionarlo como
lo solucionaron con paciencia
persistencia tolerancia es decir la
manera diplomática de presionar al
prestador de servicios para que monte el
planchón
muchas alcancías llevados a la
guillotina préstamos con altas tasas de
interés dineros que se podían o cuando
se lograba se daban cuotas a esos
préstamos para hacerle quite
a esas tasas de interés y es así como
hoy después de un año
seguimos siguen trabajando con la grúa y
les voy a contar quiénes son los
personajes de esta historia
fernando es un señor de 51 años en su
juventud fue soldado profesional
en sus años mozos fue atleta
un hombre de múltiples carreras fue
taxista
campesino calvo
y además
de padre esposo amigo es mi papá desde
1991 aquella época donde casarse con una
mujer con hijos era mal visto y aún más
que el hijo era una mujer yo que les
habla johnny 30 años ocupaciones varias
profesional en comercio exterior
deportista analista triatleta además de
ser hija hermana mayor
soy dueña de un gato
muchísimas gracias
pero las cosas no terminan acá
perdón
para recordar
a veces cuando me ven manejando la grúa
noto sacar a impresión y digo acaso no
puedo manejar una grúa si alcanzo los
pedales el problema no es mi altura el
problema es que soy mujer
cuando hago publicidad y paso las
tarjetas de presentación me preguntan
con esa cara de asombro tú manejas grúa
y yo sí pero no hago servicios
soy la manager
para finalizar
debo impedir o debo dejar de tener retos
o de realizar actividades por mi género
la respuesta es no y en mayúsculas
[Aplausos]